to us to the west watch to the west
[Music]
911 state your emergency
yes this has to do with an emergency
restraining order on my son
he happens to be at the residence i have
the police report number or whatever the
address
is west portland c-o-r-t
single one-party violation of
training order at
portland
rp just pulled up and her estranged son
is passed out by her back door
the hma 27 years old of six one wearing
dark pants and a dark black shirt
possibly high our pc there's a piece of
foil that appears burnt unknown what
type of drugs and no weapons seen
i need to give you an update
okay
he just came out of the side of the
house and he brandished again
he had on his on his waistband
he brandished to them he said inside
because they come for me i'm ready for
them
there's a fake one
okay my mother explained it to fake my
mother
i think it's a fake one here to my
knowledge he has no bullets i saw a fake
one on dirt what did it look like
uh it's just a like a toy big thing okay
well i'm on the phone right now and i
i've been outside in the house i've been
outside and i've been monitoring him to
make sure he hasn't left the house
he thought it was funny and he came out
with a gun
underneath his belt he said look there
they come for me i'm ready
that's what he said to me
okay
but you you think now it was a toy
i don't know officer i don't know okay
so what did it look like
it looked big black revolver a big black
revolver
is that white oh white electrical
he sees us russell police department
show me your hands mom back out show me
your hands
special police department show me your
hands
we have a police canine here if you take
off running we're gonna send the dog you
may be bitten by the dog come out now
so fresno police department you're
surrounded dude come out now
hey do we want to go use the garage yeah
you want to go yeah go sorry we're going
to cross we're going to cross
watch out
[Music]
up
we need to put bodies here to protect
mom moms on
oh chris go ahead and take that brief
come on
oh chris go ahead and take that brings
away your legs
chrome and color
[Music]
i okay knew i had to protect the house
yeah
[Music]
to baker tend to hutchins watch us to
the west watch to the west
show your hands gun
don't move i can't see you on the right
side you guys right side sarge
hold on hold on hold on
i can't see the gun he had his right
hand
[Music]